Now, if you were to take a look a little
more carefully at these photoreceptors,
and actually look at them for
real, you would see two types.
You would see rods and cones.
Now, we've, we've looked at this picture
before when we're talking about color,
but now we want to
talk about the anatomy.
So, the rods are these little,
skinny structures here, and there
are something like, it says 120 million
rods, plus or minus, within your retina.
They are very, very light sensitive,
about 1000 times more light sensitive
than the cones, if given time to adapt.
We'll see that in a minute.
And it can sort of help
you discriminate between,
of different illumination levels
at very low overall illumination.
The other structures here are the cones,
and we've actually seen these before.
The cones are the things that
allow you to discriminate color.
We talked about them when
we talked about the short,
medium and long wavelength cones.
The cones are also the ones
that are packed within your,
what are called your fovea.
That is that middle area that
has the very high resolution.
We'll talk about the impact
of that in a minute.
And it's the cones that give you
sort of what we tend to think
of as the high quality vision, and the
rods sort of provide everything else.
Now by the way, even if you didn't
have an electron microscope, and
even if you hadn't sort of
peeled apart peoples' retinas.
It sounds kind of gross.
You would know that there are at
least a two kinds of systems
going on in the eye.
And one of the ways that this was
discovered is what's referred to as dark
adaptation experiments, okay.
So in dark adaptation,
here's what we do.
We, we put you in a dark room for
months at a time, no.
You put somebody in a dark room, and
you, let's say after one minute,
you say, how bright a light do I have
to have a light to be before you can
tell that it's on.
Okay, if you do that?
And then later we do it all over again
and we do it for two minutes, and
then we do it for three minutes.
Right, so we track to see how
much light you need in order
to detect that there's
some illumination.
Now we've all had this
experience before right?
You walk in from a bright day light into
a dark room and it takes a little while.
We say for your eyes to adjust.
Well, that adjustment is not
your pupil opening and closing.
That's a rapid response.
What's happening is, is that the pho-,
is that the photo receptors in your eye
are adjusting to the amount of light.
All right?
And if I were to track that,
I would see this kind of a curve.
Okay, I would see a curve that
starts going down like this, and
starts to look like it's
going to flatten out.
And then somewhere, this says about
eight minutes, varies on person to
person, somewhere around there, all of
a sudden it starts to drop down again.
Okay.
What's happened is your
rods are now kicking in.
Your rods are now coming into play.
And you can go way much,
much, much lower threshold.
All right.
And so, you know, when,
when you have a single system
you never get psychfisicers that
have sharp breaks like that, right.
And basically what you're seeing
here is there are two curves.
There's a curve here for cones.
And a curve here for rods.
And this was where they intersect,
all right?
And that's the sort of well-known
phenomena which implied that there was
multiple systems within the retina
in terms of light sensitivity.